حركه النهضه هو نحكي واليوم على عادل
398 الف دينار
وكان معناها ايدي الي تساعد فيه
مواعيد مع سيف بن رحومه
ليحدثنا عن اكبر عمليه تحيل تعرض لها من
قيادي في حركه النهضه سيف ما زال تحت
تاثير الصدمه منذ سنه 9 10
بعد عملياته تهديد والهرسله والاعتداءات
الماديه من قبل عناصر محسوبه على تنظيم
الاخوان بمجرد توجهه للقضاء مطالبا
باسترجاع امواله ومقدما وثائق وادله
وتسجيلات وسكوك بنكيه لكن دون جدوى يتسلط
عليه حركه
نفوذ الدوله
شكلك مش نظيف العقد هذه وللعقده غير
قانوني تظهر هذه القصه كما يحكيها صاحبها
طريقه عمل تنظيم الاخوان في تونس في
التحيز وتبييض الاموال اليوم وبعد فتح هذه
الملفات صدرت بطاقات ايداعا بالسجن بحق
قيادات من النهضه وتحجير سفر وتجميد اصول
بنكيه مع ادراج نجل راشد الغنوشي بالتفتيش
ومع شروح القطب المالي في التحقيق في
قضايا الفساد وتبييض الاموال 13يه الاخوان
يتساءل المهتمون بقضايا مكافحه الفساد عن
امكانيه تورط هياكل الدوله في الفساد
وغياب الاراده السياسيه لمكافته
وحازنا في مساله مكافحه الفساد بسيفه عامه
وخاصه مثلت بعيد وهذا شفناها حتى في
الاحزاب السياسيه اللي مدته يديها
لمهربين ودخلوا المسجد
يعني رجال اعمال ف وتومه مشمولين بمحاكمات
ومعتع في المؤسسه القضائيه تظهر ارقام غير
رسميه ارتفاع عدد قضايا تبييض الاموال من
70 قضيه سنه 16 و 2000 الى 2200 سنه سنه
21 و 2000 مع تصاعدي المطالب بتحقيق
المحاسبه قبل فتح باب المصالحه
سجن ضربه موجعه اخرى تتلقاها منظومه
الاخوان في تونس تمس اخطبوطها الماليه
ستحسد رؤوسا كثيره من حركه النظر ما قد
يعني حل هذا الحزب قضائيا واغلاق قوس
الاسلام السياسي في البلاد بعد العشريه
السوداء وفقا متابعيننا وليد عبد الله
العربيه
تونس